Hello, this is Dr.
Plummer, and we are going
to do healing and
repair in this session,
which kind of comes
in sequence with the
cell injury and death
and inflammation.
It's kind of like
the next step,
but again, this
is all a spectrum.
These are the session
objectives, which
should be the same
as in your CPG, and
this is an overall
chart that just shows
basically what we're
going to talk about.
There's an injury,
we've discussed
that before,
and we have a
cellular and
vessel response.
And we can go
different pathways.
We can remove the
stimulus because
if it's an acute
injury, and we can
regenerate the
normal structure.
Or if it's a deep
wound with more tissue
damage, you can do
healing with scar.
Persistent tissue
damage would definitely
end up in tissue
scar, fibrosis like
you see in certain
diseases like
chronic pancreatitis.
So we're going to go
through injury and
see how this all
fits in with what
we've learned so far.
So when we talk about
repair of tissue we
mean that the tissue
architecture has to be
restored and its
function not just this
architecture after some
kind of injury and that
comes from proliferating
proliferation of the
remnants of the injured
tissue and endothelial
cells and fibroblasts
these are main tissue
but they're not the
only main cells when
we regenerate we restore
normal cells when we
lay down scar formation
we're talking about
more like collagen
deposition which we'll
get to uh when you have
extracellular matrix
framework damage,
especially extensively, you
cannot have regeneration.
You must have scar
formation because you
need that scaffold.
Pure repair with
scar usually occurs
in tissues that do
not regenerate and
we're going to talk
about what that
means. Permanent
tissue is that type
and there's other
types of tissue.
So regeneration, as
I just said, and I do
repeat myself for
points of emphasis is
the replacement of
damaged or dead cells
and or tissue by cells
of the same type and
that can happen by
proliferation of
differentiated cells that
to survive the injury
and an example that
would be in liver
and they have the
capacity to proliferate.
It also can happen
when tissue stem cells
and their progenitors
will contribute to
restoring damaged
tissue. And regeneration
really occurs with
tissues which are highly
proliferative. And
the important point
is that the basement
membrane must remain
intact and the immature
cells, the stem
cells, must remain
intact. And, very
importantly, there must
be an intact connective
tissue scaffold or
you cannot regenerate.
I've been talking a
lot about different
cells so let's just
define them. The labile
cells are those that
renew their cellular
populations. They
continuously divide.
Examples include
things like skin
and lymphoid tissue,
the bone marrow,
GI mucosa. And think
about that when
someone unfortunately
receives chemotherapy.
Those are the ones
that are affected. The
epithelial cells, the
hair, there's hair
loss. There's usually
a suppression of
the bone marrow. There's
usually vomiting,
diarrhea maybe, and
that's because of
the GI mucosa. So
that makes sense.
Then there are
stable cells, which
really they can
proliferate, but they have
a very low rate generally
of proliferating,
or they just
don't proliferate.
But they can, when
stimulated, reenter the
cell cycle. So they're
considered quiescent.
Examples of this are
so many different
cells. these are
just examples like
the liver, kidney,
smooth muscle,
parenchymal
cells mean the
cells of an organ
basically, and
all these cells
listed here.
And permanent cells
are terminally
differentiated. They're
non-dividing. They can no
longer regenerate.
Now traditionally the
examples given are
nerve tissue, cardiac
muscle, and skeletal
muscle. And nowadays they
have learned how to
regenerate some nerve
tissue and skeletal
muscle. And there is
some regeneration
going on. But for our
intents and purposes for
this particular lecture
we're going to say
that these three types
of cells are basically
permanent cells.
Now we I think we
discussed growth factors
but and you've heard
it before but these are
very important proteins
and they regulate
a lot of different
things. One of the things
they regulate is growth
and the important
source includes
macrophages but they can
come from other things
like epithelial cells
or stromal cells they're
kind of bought they
bind to specific
receptors and then they
have they signal the
target cells and this
is all very you know
cellular kind of science
here medicine the
signals will then
stimulate gene transcription
that in resting cells
is silent but then
it stimulates it and
it includes genes that
control the cell cycle
so there are a lot of
growth factors. And
right here, I'm
mentioning four of what I
think are the most
important. There are many
more. You'll hear
about a lot more, but
these four I would like
you to kind of know.
PDGF is platelet-derived
growth factor. And
one of the things it
does, it does a lot
of things, but it
causes migration and
proliferation of fibroblasts
and smooth muscle
cells and also monocytes
to inflammatory
areas. And it helps with
healing skin wounds.
VEGF, vascular
endothelial growth, is
extremely important
in angiogenesis, which
is also called
neovascularization, which
is new blood vessel
formation. And it's
what is important in
chronic inflammation
and healing, which is
why we're discussing
even in tumors. Tumors
can't grow without
a blood supply. So
they use VEGF to
produce more vessels
so they can survive.
and we do now trying
to there are some
therapies that are
anti-VEGF I don't I I'm
not a pharmacologist
so I don't know how I
don't know how well
they work some of them
do work some of
them don't work but
doctors Pino and Goldstein
may know more Dr.
Dosha Osa now factor
growth factor 2 and
you don't have to
remember that it's two.
Somebody may want you
to, but I just care
that it's FGF. It
happens to help re
-epithelialization of skin
wounds and also helps
with new blood
formation, etc. is there
because it does so
many different things.
There's really a lot
of things it does.
Tumor growth, tissue
growth factor beta is
very important
because it's extremely
powerful fibrogenic
agent. It will stimulate
collagen and enhances
the production of
collagen and it also
inhibits that collagen
should be degraded and
it's anti-inflammatory
now these are just a
list of some growth
factors please do not
memorize this one you
know someday you'll
have to go through
these all at some point
I don't require you
to memorize all this
before that I mentioned
are in bold for you
to look at because
those are what I think
are the most important
but that's from my
point of view but all
growth factors are
important and there are
many of them and this
is a limited list.
So when we want to
heal a wound because of
injury there are three
phases and we already
discussed the first
one inflammatory
phase where you have an
injury the coagulation
cascade gets
instigated there's some
platelet aggregation
and PDGF gets released
and there is the
vasodilation and all those
things we talked about
the migration the
rolling all that stuff
I'm not saying it
in order but that's
the acute and chronic
inflammatory response
so we're not really
going to discuss
that that was already
discussed what we're
going to talk about is
the proliferation phase
and maturation phase
and important things
include in the
proliferation phase something
known as granulation
tissue and we're
going to talk about
that it's very important
and of course scar
tissue which is in
the maturation phase.
So when we repair things
by scar connective
tissue because it's
basically fibrosis you
know we go through
inflammation first
angiogenesis new blood
vessels fibroblasts come
in and proliferate
and they form a scar
and this is very important
and the prototype
of this a good example
is skin and we're
going to go through
that in a little bit
but most healing is
not either regeneration
or repair but kind of
a combination of both
and it really depends
on the kind of injury
the ability of the
tissue cells to
regenerate or proliferate
how the extracellular
matrix is damaged the
integrity of it if
the scaffold is there
that's good and any
chronic inflammation
that's hanging out so
let me talk about
granulation tissue, which
is one of the most
important concepts,
especially if you're
going to go into surgery.
This is when you
have the migration
and proliferation
of fibroblasts.
And there's deposition
of connective
tissue, which
is kind of loose
in the beginning,
and new vessels.
And those new vessels,
that's known as
androgenesis. And the
white cells in this
phase are usually
mostly macrophages.
When you first
start, graduation
tissue, the type
3 collagen is what
is first
synthesized. That's
immature. That's
non-mature collagen.
And of course, all
these interactions
take place through
growth factors. And the
extracellular matrix,
which I'm going
to talk a little bit
about, but is more
of a cellular pathology
thing, but not
really a pathology
pathology, are things
like glycoproteins
and proteoglycans.
And you need the
glycoproteins to cross-link
the collagen fibers
to make them strong.
That's one of the
things they do. and you
need proteoglycans for
hydrating that ECM,
that gel formation. So
this is a picture of
granulation tissue
or angiogenesis. The
endothelial cells, the
lining of the vessels
will grow extensions
toward the wound site
and the extensions are
called pseudopodia.
The cells will
divide and then they
create a new lumen and
the main control of
this is VEGFA. You
know, I don't need
you to talk, you
know, know necessarily
that it's A. I
mean, that's in the
book. But the important
thing to remember
is vascular endothelial
growth factor.
Again, I'm going
through these four
again because I think
they're important.
The EGF, most
important growth
factor, especially
in wound healing.
And it promotes
vasodilation, stimulates
production of nitric
oxide. Remember,
that's a vasodilator
like histamine. And
also vessel permeability
increased. And we
went through some of
this in inflammation
and also in cellular
injury and death.
VEGF-A, which is,
I guess, a subtype,
is the most important
in angiogenesis
because of its
ability to proliferate
and move endothelial
cells. And we'll
talk a little bit
more about that.
I would never ask you
a question saying,
you know, giving you
two choices in that,
like VEGF and VEGF
-A. I won't do that.
just so you know the
VEGFA is more specific
and and it's really
very important in
angiogenesis and I
already talked about FGF
promoting migration of
macrophages and fibroblasts
and remember that
newly formed vessels
in a wound or anywhere
are very fragile and
they need to be
stabilized and that means
they're going to be
recruiting what are known
as parasites and
smooth muscle cells and
ECM proteins will be
deposited and the kind
of things that help
regulate that are the
ones listed here like
angiopoietin 1 and 2
etc PDGF TGF beta and
they help stabilize.
Okay so this is a picture
of some angiogenesis
new blood vessel
developing from an
existing blood vessel
and the parasites which
are not parasite
parasite it's my Jersey
accent are on at the
edge of the vessel as
you can see here in
the picture and they're
on the abluminal
surface which means the
opposite of the lumen
they break down the
basement membrane and
they form a little sprout
as you see in the
picture here and then
the endothelial cells
will migrate towards
the tissue injury by
being stimulated and then
the endothelial
cells proliferate and
mature and periendothelial
cells, more parasites,
more smooth muscle
cells are recruited
to form mature vessels.
And down here is
just basically the
caption for this picture.
You're seeing angiogenesis
by the sprouting
of a new vessel,
formation of new vessel.
Okay, so now we need
to worry about the
connective tissue. and
that is going to be
mostly collagen although
there are things in it
and you're going to
need fibroblasts to
migrate to the area and
to proliferate and the
fibroblasts don't
just secrete collagen
or make collagen but
they deposit ECM proteins
this is all orchestrated
by growth factors
cytokines like the
ones I've already
mentioned and the most
time the sources of that
are macrophages that
although they can come
from other sources
like in the field of
epithelial cells, but
mostly M2 macrophages.
So we already talked
about the acute
injury and 24 hours
and the neutrophils
coming, but when you
get to the 48-hour
mark, the more
dominant cell is the
macrophage. And again,
it doesn't mean that
all the neutrophils
disappear and
macrophages show up.
It's a process, and
you'll see that in a
graph I have later.
What's controlling
the fibroblasts
are mostly
macrophages, and the
migration is done
by different types
of chemokines,
growth factors, etc.
And again, I want
to reiterate that
TGF-beta is very
important in making
fibrous tissue,
fibrinogenesis.
Fibroblasts will
create the matrix of
type 3 collagen,
which is the immature
one, and fibronectin.
And that at first,
like I said, was
immature, and it
has only about a 10
% tensile strength.
When collagen,
type 1 collagen,
which is mature,
replaces everything,
when you have full
scar tissue, it
says here three
months. It could be
two months, three
months. Again, it's
not a perfect number.
Your tensile strength
is about 70% to
80% of what it
originally was. It
doesn't really return
to 100% in scars.
The extracellular
matrix, which
you've heard about,
is important because
it's what is the
mechanical support
for cells. and
it's important in
anchoring the cells
and migration.
It controls cell
growth because
it regulates cell
proliferation
by signaling
via receptors,
especially the
endocrine family.
And it is the scaffold,
that's important,
a scaffold for
tissue renewal,
okay? If you
destroy a lot of it,
you're not gonna be
able to regenerate.
Establishment of a
tissue microenvironment
is very important, and
that's what ECM does.
the basement membrane
is what's between the
epithelium and the
underlying connective
tissue. So you want
to keep that intact if
you want to have
epithelialization or else
you're going to have
a really big scar.
I'm not going to really
go on and on about
the ECM. I think you
have other recordings
and lectures about
this. Just realize that
there are two forms,
interstitial matrix and
basement membrane and
that this is a picture
from Robbins I believe
showing you know the
basement membrane which
contains by the way
the laminin or type
and type 4 collagen
which is kind of
important for the basement
membrane and it just
shows you where everything
is and you know it's
one big scaffold
basically and the
epithelium sits on top those
cells on blue cells
on top okay so there's
collagens and elastic
fibers in the extracellular
matrix which give
you that strength.
Adhesive glycoproteins
I had mentioned earlier
and that's important
to connect the
elements and to each
other and proteoglycans
which helps with
lubrication and resilience.
Now please don't
memorize the formation of
collagen for me. Somebody
else may want you
but I'm not going
to ask you about the
formation of collagen
but you do need to know
that collagen is laid
down by fibroblast, and
that's in the proliferative
phase of repair
and modified in the
maturation phase. And
collagen itself is
made up of three alpha
chains that form a
triple helix. That's kind
of important. So when we
go from pre-procollagen
to pro-collagen to
collagen, and again,
I'm not going to
ask you about that
biochemistry, although
you may need to know it
for somebody else, there's
a lot of modification,
and you need vitamin
C, which kind of
explains why scurvy
happens. If you don't
have enough vitamin
C, you will have skin
issues because you don't
have mature collagen
and the collagen is
not produced correctly.
So there, just so you
know, there are many
types of collagen. And
again, please do not
memorize one through
whatever this is, 13,
16, whatever. There
are a lot. And with
each one, there is a
disease associated with
it. And we're not going
to talk about these
diseases now, but I
just want you to realize
how important collagen
is and how many
diseases it could form.
Now, some of these
are extremely rare.
I've never seen, but we
have an Erlos-Danlos
clinic here at NYIT
-COM. So you see how
important that is for in
a, for collagen three
and five especially.
And there are other
things that we'll talk
about in bone, osteogenic
genesis imperfecta,
and also Erlos Danlos.
There are four,
the four bean types that
you want to remember
are the ones that
I've listed, but type
one and three are
really, really, really
important, which is
why they're in red. So
type one is the mature
collagen. It's very
high tensile strength.
We're talking about
tendons, bones, and
scars. It's mature.
Type three is immature.
This is the first
collagen that is
deposited in wound
healing. so it's not
as tensile it's not
as strong and then
two is mostly in
cartilage and other
things like the vitreous
humor and four i
mentioned is associated
with laminin in the
basement membrane
again i don't want you
to memorize this slide
either but these are
just some examples of
glycoproteins and
proteoglycans and what
they do this is more
biochemistry but i want
you to realize if i
say the word you know
fibronectin that you
know i'm talking about
something in the
extracellular matrix okay and
we've talked about
integrins as well so
just this is more of a
slide for supplemental
information I don't
need it I know you're
gonna probably study
this in another session
so this is a really
good explanation of a
skin injury a cutaneous
injury the three phases
you have the inflammation
which we have
discussed that's phase
one then the proliferation
and then the maturation
and as you can
see and what i'm trying
to emphasize here are
they they're really an
artificial construct
this is a spectrum it's
a dynamic overlapping
process it's not
like all of a sudden
the inflammation disappears
and then the next
step happens no this is
all kind of happening
along a spectrum and
you can see that in
the chart that's attached
so these are this
is a chart again a
little smaller but down
on the bottom that's
kind of important because
if you remember i
told you you know the
neutrophils come in
first and the macrophages
come in last I mean,
not last, I'm sorry,
second, around 48 hours,
around two days, but
it's not like all the
neutrophils disappear.
They go down. They're
still there at like
four days, but it's
the macrophages that
are predominant. The
fibroblasts come in, all
these things, again,
there's an overlap. So,
but if I tell you
something is 48 hours,
what's the dominant
cell? The answer is
macrophages. Yeah,
neutrophils are there, but
they're not the dominant
cell at 48 or two days
to 96 to three days
or four days so the
immediate thing that
happens is within two to
four days you get the
formation of clot when
you have an injury we
talked a little bit
about cell damage and
bacteria acute inflammation
we discussed vasodilation
and phagocytosis
and the neutrophils
that come in within
24 hours and peak
about then or a little
bit later i mean again
it's not a perfect number
and it may vary from
person to person but
then after the
neutrophils start falling,
you will get the influx
of the macrophages.
So in phase two, we're
talking about two
days to three weeks.
Again, these are artificial
kind of phases. You
know, I'm just trying
to make it a little
simpler. And again,
you have a little
graph on top. And what
you see is the
development of granulation
tissue, very important,
in which fibroblasts
come in to lay down
collagen and in which
angiogenesis occurs,
the development of new
blood vessels. What
you see on the bottom
is granulation tissue
on the left you see a
lot of red and all that
red is blood vessels
and there's some loose
connective tissue
in there on the right
is a special stain and
it's a special stain
for collagen or for
fibroblast or fibrous
tissue and it's
blue it because
that's what it stains
fibrous tissue so
the vessels are still
there but as you
can tell the fibrous
tissue is starting to
develop here as you
go later and later
into angiogenesis
so phase three is the
maturation and that's
when type three
collagen is replaced by
type one so you get
your tensile strength
about 70 to 80 percent
you need to remodel make
sure that the scar
the scar tissue is not
does not have vessels
it's avascular and
acellular and sometimes
if the wound is big
enough like in this
case unfortunately
there's wound contraction
the wound edges pull
together and they do
so to close the defect
via myofibroblasts.
And these are basically
fibroblasts that have
muscle filaments.
Okay, combination of
regeneration repair
and the best example of
that is a skin wound.
That's what's classically
taught. There's
first intention and
second intention.
Healing by first intention
or primary union is
basically the
regeneration of the skin,
the epithelium. And
when the injury only
involves the epithelial
layer, you get first
intention healing. So
an example would be a
nice clean linear
surgical excision because
you have really a
limited number of skin
cells that die and
even connective tissue.
The second intention
healing is when you have
a really big area
wound a gapping hole
basically when you have
a lot of tissue loss.
They are not easily
aligned together the
epithelial cells and
there's a much more intense
inflammatory reaction
and a lot of granulation
tissue, which I
showed you before a
picture of. And then you
get a lot of collagen.
So you're going to get
quite a large scar.
So here's a
beautiful picture of
healing by first
intention or
primary union.
This is a surgical
incision.
You will get some
inflammation, but not as
bad as when it's secondary
healing, a secondary
intention and this
happens again the wounds
are very they have
opposed edges they can
be easily brought
together and it involves
only the epithelial
layer and so this is an
example of that with
the surgical sutures.
Healing by secondary
intention is most
other things where
you have basically
you know a big
wound and a lot of
extensive cell loss
and tissue loss and the
edges are not able
to come together.
They're separated,
like in this case.
In this case, regeneration
of the cells can't
completely restore the
original architecture.
So granulation tissue
has to grow from
the margin and help
complete the repair. So
granulation tissue is
very, very important.
Here's another example
side-by-side of first
and second intention
healing. as you can
tell in this cartoon
on the left in the
first intention healing
the wound is minor
it's minor and there's
a lot less injury
there's a lot less
destruction of tissue whereas
on the right the second
intention there's
a big wound here
and look at all this
angiogenesis and over
here on the right middle
a lot more blood
vessels than you see
over here in the first
intention and that's
around again three to
seven days is around
the time this granulation
tissue is coming
and weeks later the
epithelium and a scar
nice nice healing and
whereas where you get a
really bad scar you
need to have wound the
contraction of the wound
and etc so the wound
contraction occurs
in really big surface
wounds that are going to
be healing by secondary
intention we're talking
about skin wounds
here and what it does
is helps close the
gap between the edges
of the skin and the
dermis and reduces the
surface area of the
wound and I mentioned
the myofibroblast before
so I'm repeating myself
like I often do and
again remember that
myofibroblasts contain
characteristics
of both muscle
cells and fibrous
tissue and
they help
contract the wound
again via growth
factors like listed here
that are usually released
mostly by macrophages
only by macrophages
no but mostly by
macrophages okay so
now when you have a big
wound and you have
to remodel it uh the
granulation tissue is
replaced by scar and this
is going to involve changes
in the extracellular
matrix and there's
going to you're
going to have to rely on
a sin the body's going
to have to rely on
between the synthesis
and degradation of
extracellular proteins.
And that's where matrix
metalloproteinases
come in. There are
enzymes which degrade
and they're very
important in this balance.
These matrix
metalloproteinases are here
about again. They're
produced by a lot of
different cells as listed
and they are made and
secreted and regulated
by growth factors and
cytokines, etc. So
here's some examples
that are listed underneath.
Again, I don't need
you to memorize that
interstitial collagenases,
cleave, fibrillary
collagen. I just
want you to understand
there's many different
ones. And what stops
this from happening?
What's the balance
between degradation and
synthesis? Well,
there's something called
tissue inhibitors of
metalloprotonases, and
they're what shut down
the metalloprotonases
so that they don't
continue to degrade again
we discussed this the
tensile strength of
the wound depends on
the amount of collagen
and also you want the
the degradation to
decrease right so by
the again i'm repeating
myself end of first
week wound strength is
about 10 percent in the
unwounded skin and after
a few months two to
three it plateaus at
about 70 to 80 percent
so this is another
overview picture where
you have a persistent
stimulus like chronic
inflammation that is
activating things like
macrophages which act
you know goes ahead
and produces growth
factors cytokines and
decreases metallic proteinase
activity and that
all leads basically
to increase collagen
synthesis from the
fibroblast etc and decrease
collagen degradation
and you get fibrosis
and fibrosis is just
basically scar scarring
now i'm going to talk
about this one slide
talks about regeneration
of the liver i'm not
i'm i just feel you
don't you can't graduate
from medical school
without knowing a
little bit about the
liver is a little bit
different than a lot of
organs because it can
regenerate it's really
kind of strange but
you can do 60 percent
hepectomy hepatectomy
i'm sorry the
liver um and you
will get liver back
and the tissue back
and mechanism is
the proliferation of
what remains behind
the remaining liver
cells and also
repopulation from
progenitor cells.
So this is means that
the hepatocytes you
know they they divide
and they have a
proliferative capacity
but sometimes they're
impaired this capacity
especially in like
alcoholic liver disease
and things like that.
I want just to emphasize
the regeneration of
liver is not just
regrowth of the lobes you
know but it does occur
in phases listed here
primary where the
liver cells are again
primed by cytokines which
are made by macrophages
and in the liver when
we talk about the
liver the macrophages
are called cuffer cells
again they like to call
macrophages different
things in different
tissue and there's a
growth factor phase
and a termination phase
i'm just mentioning
this i want you to put
this in the back of your
head but this is the
liver is a little bit
different than what
we've been talking about
wounds of the skin.
Now what is going
to get in the way
of healing okay of
a wound and again
this is very
important in surgery.
An infection okay a
local infection that's
why sterile technique
is so important. If
you get pro-inflammatory
cytokines and tissue
proteases they will
degrade that granulation
tissue and you cannot
have a good uh repair
or or scar uh hypoxia
if you have a loss
of if the blood vessels
and the blood rbcs
don't bring enough
oxygen then you're going
to have a problem
with wound healing and
that happens with
inadequate circulation
arteriosclerosis things
like that uh diabetes for
example trauma uh if
you have a trauma to
i mean if you're all
you know have a nice
wound there that somebody
stitched and then
you go and rip it
open for some you know
because you you stood
the wrong way that's not
good foreign bodies
that's why we debride
wounds the foreign
bodies are things like
rocks and glass and
things from motorcycle
accidents um you know
bullets things like that
they have to be
debrided they have to be
taken out or else you're
going to have a problem
with wound healing and
I mentioned diabetes
because you got
glycosylation that will
impair neutrophil and
macrophagocytosis and
you'll learn more
about that in diabetes
malnutrition like I
mentioned scurvy will
decrease the proliferation
phase immunodeficiency
some medications like
steroids will blunt
the inflammatory
process etc hormones and
the mechanics of the
like if you have a wound
right over the elbow
joint that's gonna
be a little harder you
have to keep it in a
certain state so again
everything depends on
the size the location
the type of wound
remember the face is
very very vascular and it
heals faster than
something like the foot
which is not so vascular
complications well
there are a lot of
complications but the big
ones i want you to
know about are wound
dehiscence and
ulceration uh keloid and
contractures and in wound
dehiscence basically
you don't have enough
scar formation and the
wound just comes apart
in excessive scar
formation we have the
formation of what is known
as keloids which is
basically scar tissue
that extends beyond
the boundaries of the
original wound which is
more common in darker
skinned people but
can happen in anyone.
I want to make the
distinction between keloid
and hypertrophic scar.
A hypertrophic scar
means you have a lot
an excessive amount
of collagen and get a
raised scar but it does
not extend beyond the
boundary of the original
wound and then
contractures that happen
in palms and soles
especially in burn victims
where you get lot of
contracture so this
is a person who had
a dehiscence of their
wound very commonly
this happens um i should
say most commonly in
abdominal surgery and
obesity can contribute
to it vomiting coughing
can you burst the
wound open so there's
some increased abdominal
pressure and that
can happen and of
course that's not good
ulceration especially
in poor circulation like
in diabetes and peripheral
vascular disease.
And this is a
very good example,
a bad example,
if you will, of
a keloid from
an ear piercing.
And again, I want you
to know that keloid
and hypertrophic scars
are two different things.
In keloid, you have
a lot of collagen
forming. It's very
disorganized. It extends
beyond the borders of
the bone. And the problem
with keloids, and this
is really upsetting
because I once saw
this in a plastic
surgery clinic, they
frequently recur after you
so you take out the
scar the high keloid
and you get more keloid
it's extremely difficult
to treat extremely
difficult um hypertrophic
is parallel collagen
it's confined to
the borders of the
original wound and it
doesn't really recur if
you remove it okay so
this is something um
that's important in wound
healing uh and you
want to it is treated
different ways and I
don't deal with treatment,
but I want you to
know the difference.
So now we're going to
just review and then
do some questions and
be done with this.
This is basically, I
don't have to read it
all to you, but this
is a review of what
I just said about VEGF
being important with
vessel permeability,
the neutrophils in
24 hours to clean
out everything, and
macrophages by about 48
to 96 again not an exact
number and angiogenesis
extracellular
matrix deposition the
fibroblasts migrate to
the injury site and
that's all orchestrated
by things like cytokines
and these growth
factors and they
proliferate the fibroblasts
mostly coming by
growth factors that
come from the macrophages
so at 24 to 48 hours
the epithelial cells
move from the wound
edge along the margins
of the dermis and
they put down basement
membrane components
and you get a nice
thin epithelial layer.
When you have a bigger
wound, you need an
increase in collagen
fibers to bridge that.
Again, I want to mention
granulation tissue
five to seven days is
about four to seven
days, five to seven
days. That is really the
presence of
angiogenesis or vascular
endothelial cells
proliferating and fibroblasts
and also macrophages
are there. So it's like
three really big
elements that are there.
Neovascularization is the
same thing as
angiogenesis.
By the second week,
if everything goes
well, your white
cells should be gone.
Your inflammation should
be gone if you want
to heal. So should
the edema and the
increase in vascularity.
And I'm going to repeat
myself from something
in the beginning.
TGF beta is one of
the most important
fibrogenic agent, and it
causes the fibroblasts
to migrate and
proliferate and, of
course, increased
synthesis of collagen.
Okay, so again,
this is just a more
continuation of
what I've just said,
and a lot of this
is repetition.
Scar is a cellular
connective tissue. There's
no inflammation in
it, and it's usually
covered by intact
epithelium, not always.
Okay, so let's do a few
questions. Okay, this
first question you
can read. You can stop
the video, whatever you
want to do, and it's
about an experiment
that's being conducted
on the effects of
certain drugs on wound
healing and the uh they
give them a drug a and
they make a cut in the
thigh of a lab rat and
one week later a biopsy
is taken from that
area and when you look
under the microscope
you see capillaries
fibroblasts and some
inflammatory cells
mostly macrophages with
some occasional
neutrophils so what are we
talking about are we
talking about scar tissue
granulan granulation
tissue purulent tissue
or permanent tissue
and hopefully after
this you understand
that this answer is B as
in boy granulation
tissue okay this is not
scar tissue scar
tissue does not have
vessels or inflammation
purulent tissue means
pus also known as super
super super super and
permanent tissue of
things like nerves and
and and skeletal muscle
and cardiac muscle
next question is a
70 year old woman who
comes in with shortness
of breath and chest
pain obviously we're
going here along with
a myocardial infarction
she undergoes cardiac
catheterization which
shows that the left
anterior descending
coronary artery is
occluded and all the
lab studies that occur
in the EKG show that
indeed she has an acute
MI so which of the
following is the most
likely pathological
finding in that affected
heart muscle six weeks
later again we're
talking about cardiac
muscle which does not
regenerate by six weeks
you should not have
vessels or inflammation
what you should have
is is a good start if
not you know almost
ending of this of the
scar tissue so the
answer here is d as
in david collagen rich
scar tissue the other
answers are incorrect
third question is a 10
year old boy who gets
a deep laceration
over his right eyebrow
when he plays ice hockey
they clean the wound
they suture it which
of the following
describes the principal
function of macrophages
that are present in
that wound about 48
hours after injury
again it's approximate
and hopefully your eyes
would go straight to
d as in david
phagocytosis and
that at that
moment 48 hours
that's what's
most important
that the macrophages are
doing are phagocytosis
in the previous
question which of the
following college and
there's a positive
first during wound
healing so this is a type
you know a first order
question just whether
you know it or not
and just remember
that the first one or
the immature one is
type three so the answer
is c as in charlie
and type one is the
mature here's a summary
slide and the lecture
feedback form thank
you very much for your
attention please feel
free to email me come
by my office anything
you need to reach
me and i'll be happy
to answer any questions
thanks a lot again